hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
Damen und Herren herzlich willkommen
heute endlich mal wieder zu einer
Episode TV mit Luca aber ein bisschen
anders denn ich werde heute mit einer
Maske auftreten
ich bin gespannt ob mich irgendwer
kennen wird und on top seht ihr auch
habe ich hier vorne noch die ganzen
Sachen rausgeräumt
[Musik]
hallo
gut
jeder Weg
[Musik]
haben die Angst vor dieser Maske nicht
gefährlich aus
[Musik]
was geht was geht
krassen Maske Digger
warum drückst du mich dann weg der
krasse Maske und drückt mich weg
[Musik]
wie geht's dir
immer noch gut
und dir ja
ich habe eine Frage
warum die Maske
[Musik]
manchmal ist das so unangenehm wenn ich
da drück ich einfach auf dann bin ich
irgendwie nicht mehr dass ich genau die
jetzt schon zweimal getroffen hat eine
viertel Millionen Leute online
[Musik]
aber der eine Hintergrund meinte ich
sehe aus wie laserluca also anscheinend
ist es möglich mich zu erkennen aber
trotzdem drückt mich alle weg
hallo hallo
cooler Maske danke schön coole Cap danke
schön mir ist richtig schlecht unter der
Maske mittlerweile
die ist so am gammeln oh mein Gott
getroffen sehr gut aber der Typ hat
wirklich cool weil er halt nicht wie
99,9 % aller anderen auch mit TV
Benutzer einfach im Bett lag der war
draußen unterwegs das war richtig nice
hallo
[Musik]
du scheiße
Alter krass
[Musik]
kranker Typ Alter
die habe ich so echt ja also
Screenshot machen
danke
hast du mich mit der Maske nicht erkannt
nein
Alter sehr gut das sind die Momente für
die man das macht
nojob das sind die Momente wofür man
diesen ganzen Krams macht da wie geil
war das guck mal ich habe mit dem jetzt
gesprochen mit der Maske und uns gut
verstanden er hat er seine Tricks ein
bisschen gemacht aber ich Maske
abgezogen und erst dann hat er mich
erkannt was netter Kerl der war vorher
schon so Korrektur guck mal ich kann
auch dieses Kameras in netter Junge
wirklich sehr sehr sehr nett
hallo
[Musik]
ist eine Youtuber
ich habe den früher mal geschaut ja mach
mal seine Stimme an wenn das Geld ich
habe früher mal sein Podcast geschaut
S
[Musik]
der übelst beschissen aus
wie ich doch nein
ja also witzig war es nicht ich bin der
OP leider hatte ich Durchfall auch dann
kam eins zum anderen
dieser chillt ihr denn im Zimmer der
Mutter bin auch tote Vorhänge da im
Hintergrund bin ich ganz ehrlich
die Vorhänge sind schön die sehen aus
wie so eine Oma Tischdecke
wo wohnt ihr so grob Hamburg
[Musik]
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocken
schreibt mir unten in die Kommentare was
ich im nächsten Moment TV Video
besonderes machen soll und ich muss so
doll kacken